un jeune sur deux douteraient de ses
compétences pour réussir son parcours si
l'on en croit le dernier sondage
opinionway dévoilé la semaine dernière
un sondage qui révèle aussi que les
parents ne sont pas toujours d'un grand
secours pour faire les bons choix
d'orientation il ya 30 40 ans nos
parents et grands parents
choisissez un métier posés çà
généralement quasiment toute leur vie on
sait aujourd'hui que une grande partie
de ces jeunes exerceront ahmeti qui est
totalement inconnu ce jour on parle de
plus de 50% meti qui vont se créer ça
veut dire que d'autres vont mourir donc
ça veut dire que certains se
questionnent sur comment bien se
préparer à l'évolution du monde dans
lequel on évolue aujourd'hui
cette année la nuit des métiers de
montigny le bretonneux a donc ouvert ses
portes aux étudiants pour évoquer leur
parcours à leurs cadets à cette mère a
échangé avec une étudiante en médecine
on a échangé la première année de
médecine donc la rose senti
savoir au niveau de l'intensité des
cours
ben ce que ça représentait donc
mon fils voilà qui est hésitant
aujourd'hui ça lui permettra de d'avoir
déjà davantage d'informations sur le
sujet mais c'est bien la réforme du bac
qui est la disparition des filières
traditionnelles qui suscite le plus
d'inquiétude si l'on en croit les
parents présents à des changements
encore faim sachs les options mais
disons qu'on allait tu n'en as pas
forcément les aboutissants les chemins
pour y aller tant que ça c'est encore
mon investigation complète dès l'an
prochain les lycéens choisiront des
spécialités afin de mieux appréhender
l'enseignement supérieur d'où
l'importance de faire les meilleurs
choix
enfin le pôle jeunesse a aussi présenté
des solutions alternatives aux jeunes en
rupture de scolarité du service civique
à la mobilité européenne elle si vous
avez manqué ce rendez vous il est
possible de venir se renseigner tout au
long de l'année